in my opinion when you empower
individual people to make decisions
they tend to make more coherent
decisions and they tend to make better
decisions
your business strategy has to be
fundamentally different
be around high functioning high quality
people
and just copy the [ __ ] that they do
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
top 10
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you
are probably the most ambitious person
in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best chamath pala hapatia and my take on
his top
10 religious success enjoy okay let's
kick it off with rule number one
learn how to invest i started
as a day trader effectively meaning on
the side i would speculate
in my you know teens and in my 20s an
investor is not a speculator and it's
not a day trader
um and i think that a lot of retail a
lot of normal people the only way they
will close the inequality
gap is because they take it upon
themselves to learn how to become an
investor
the government's not going to save them
no law is going to save them
no you know taxation of the rich is
going to save them
they can save themselves and you have to
learn how to invest which is to
put money into the things you care about
and then do nothing maybe i can just
give you an insight into how
i process any opportunity sure company
random company comes in
uh to the top of the funding immediately
i'm making a very quick
hopefully it's a decision but maybe
sometimes it's a judgment
and i'm asking myself does this fit into
my world view or not meaning is it
is it in my circle of confidence and i
have a very simple way of looking at
this
is it going to fix something inequality
that i think is important or is it going
to fix something in climate change that
i think is important those are the only
two things i care about
inequality and climate change under
inequality there's a bunch of stuff
financial equality is important health
care equality is important
education equality is important so it
allows me to organize
a lot of different opportunities
and i'm trying to figure out is there a
consumer proposition here that's
important for them
does it make something more symmetric
does it take something that was
asymmetric and fix it so that's my first
judgment which is
qualitative that's why whenever i start
my one pager it's always
what is the strategy and you can read
all of these one pages now
and what you'll get away from them is
the first lens is equality
and or climate change
then i start to do the fundamental work
and you know this is where
i have a real issue with a lot of people
who say that they're value investors
i think that i'm a valued investor um
the thing is that when you look up the
word value in the dictionary it doesn't
mean
cheap it doesn't mean a cigar but with
two puffs
you know that famous buffett monger club
i think it actually means something that
has value
and so then i'm really thinking about
you know what are the cash flows of this
business
how does it create a moat right meaning
in software some technological way
that's hard for people to
compete with it and then can i get it
for a price
where there's a margin of safety where
if they miss execute for a quarter or if
they have a little hiccup
it's gonna be okay because you know
we've got an entry point where
five or ten years from now this thing
will be
five to ten times bigger and that's how
we think about all these things and if
you look at the deals that i've done
they kind of map pretty singularly one
to one to that
framework rule number two empower people
i actually
i'm not that interested in a bunch of
social good i'll be honest with you
i'm interested in change i'm basically
convinced that people right now who are
in positions of power
are there for completely the wrong
reasons and shouldn't be
and so the question is well how do you
change the dynamics and the cycle of
power and the balance of power
and in my opinion when you empower
individual people to make decisions
they tend to make more coherent
decisions and they tend to make better
decisions
and so when you look at a lot of sort of
the problems that are ailing the united
states or ailing the world
these are problems that bureaucracies
have created so
you know why is it that we all talk
about how
education is the most important thing in
the world and
every politician to get elected has to
have a position on education
but there's more than a trillion dollars
of student debt
it's the most encumbered sort of thing
that an individual has to deal with
at the tail end of spending all of this
money now there's no guarantee of a job
or any really meaningful employment and
then the worst thing is if you actually
go bankrupt that's the one thing that
won't get expunged
and so you can see how like the system
is sort of tilted against you
it's really great rhetoric right but all
of these people have no incentive to
actually change the system
and so from my perspective um i'm more
interested in sort of creating a dynamic
where actually people are empowered and
can live
kind of like you know lives where they
are self-sufficient economically they
can do whatever they want they can buy
the things they need they can have a
great life
and if you look to these people
who again we've created we've put as
false idols they're just going to let
you down and they've let us down
and so i feel like technology and smart
you know people can creatively solve
these problems in ways that policy and
other things can't
and so i just want to do that because i
think it's the right thing to do rule
number three
find your drive you did grow up poor
how you put it tough situation
yeah it was great how uh no seriously it
was the best thing that ever happened to
me well so i mean seriously was it
it was incredible i mean at the time it
was horrible of course uh
i lived above a laundromat uh in ottawa
ontario in a little
french ghetto called vanier but i went
to a really good
i went to a really good high school
listener collegiate every little
rich muckety-muck went there i didn't
uh and so i secretly hated all of them
but what it really was doing was
lighting this
unbelievable fire this like nuclear
reactor inside my stomach
where i'm just like i am just going to
win and uh
you know it wasn't really until waterloo
where it started to really unlock
again particularly in these work terms
where i was in the work environment
i can crush i just knew that i could do
it uh
yeah so in hindsight it was the best
thing now
in part of it why was the best thing is
i've now taken enough time to be
introspective to self-actualize
and to deal with it but it came with
immense amount of baggage you know
for a while it was like i just needed to
be rich
because i was so poor and then you get
there and then you're like wow this is
really going to amplify either the best
parts of my character
or the absolute worst parts of your
character and there was probably a year
where it was the worst parts of my
character but i
again it's like for me it's been it's
been a process a journey of
self-learning
and um yeah it was a hugely instrumental
thing like i look at my children and i'm
like wow
like what boundary conditions could i
possibly even remotely give them
that will allow them to struggle in a
way that makes them want to achieve
great things
rule number four be unique your business
strategy
has to be fundamentally different what
do i mean by that
if you are in the business of being a
parasite on top of google
your medium-term and long-term prospects
are terrible you're an impaired company
you don't know it if you
haven't figured out how to be unique
you're in a really tough situation if
you're a unique company that's
increasingly become more
more competitive and similar to
everybody else you're running towards
the google buzz saw versus away from it
and so you know travel is really
interesting because it is
one of the few canaries in the coal mine
about what their true long-term business
goals and strategy
and real issues are and you see it play
out with you know trip advisor and
expedia
um you know some part of it is miss
execution as we talked about some part
of it but
it can be a bunch of things but at the
core of it is a decision
that they will capture the overwhelming
majority of profit in the travel sector
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief i've
created a special
free program called 254 because the sign
says that it takes up to 254 days of
consecutive action to build a habit
that's what i'm going to do is send you
an unlisted video to your email
every day for 254 days for free
to help your confidence and self-belief
shift forward
the link to join is in the description
below you were up and dressed and ready
to go before your parents were up
you know why because you knew something
unexpected was going to happen
that's how we should live our lives
waking up with the understanding
to expect the unexpected one of the real
reasons we don't do the things that
frighten us
is because we are afraid of being judged
rule number five
emulate best practices a lot of my life
quite honestly just copying things that
i see
there's not a lot of original thought
here it truly is not i mean
we can all pretend we're all geniuses
honestly be good copiers
do you know what i'm saying it's the
best thing in the world
like be around high functioning high
quality people
and just copy the [ __ ] that they do
observe the [ __ ] that's you know kind of
crappy and then don't do that stuff
it's not a complicated formula
when have you used that best no all the
time
i mean look now it's funny like it's
it's like you know like you have a
surface area of ways to spend your time
now or i do
and you know i'm in this mix now where
we are really scaling up
what we're doing as a business and
i meet these people that to me are so
iconic that they were
sort of like arms length people that are
now sitting face to face
and they treat me like a quasi-peer i
wouldn't say appear but quasi-pure
but what i see is
i see some amazing stuff and i see some
utter dysfunction
in some of the richest most important
people in the world
and i have to decide how am i going to
act
what am i going to embody what am i
copying what am i not copying
and so i get a chance to now
refine my decision making and discipline
and it's so that that's how i that's how
it plays out i don't know if i answered
your question
rule number six execute revolution
starts in evolution so
you could have the biggest craziest
audacious idea in the world but unless
you can put one foot in front of the
other
and make that first step you're screwed
and none of it matters
and again all it does is it may allow
you to
you know wrap yourself in some really
elegant rhetoric maybe it allows you to
you know be really followed on twitter
and appear at tech conference
none of that matters all of that crap
washes out in the end
because if you suck you suck right and
you may be articulate but if you suck
it don't matter and you'll be revealed
to be a sham
what matters there is again it's just
that ability to
understand what that first
specific set of things need to be
um with that broader bigger goal in mind
but if you can't put your first foot in
front of the other
and you know what's amazing most people
can't um because they get wrapped up in
the rhetoric of the vision and the
mission and all of this
you know grand deals you know blobbity
blind
that they screw up and they're their own
worst enemies i i like revolution like i
like disruption
right um but i'm skeptical that that
thing start that way i think things
let's just say ultimately five years
from now we look back and we think that
there is a massive sea change
politically
in the arab world because of the arab
spring
that fruit vendor self-immolated because
he was frustrated
now maybe he started a revolution but
you know that took courage to do what he
did
that's not right or wrong in my opinion
but my point is you know
that's an example of how a revolution
started with you know a small
or not a small thing i mean it's a big
thing but um one thing that was
tractable within him
and i think these broad-based kind of
like you know
i don't know gnarly expressions of like
how all of these huge crazy things can
happen
they happen over many many many many
many years these are massive tectonic
plates
it all boils down to one person doing
one thing and i think that for a lot of
people that's hard still
rule number seven acquire skills we are
in this really huge
secular transition away from degrees
towards skills
it no longer matters where you went to
school what you did
don't tell me you have an mba it's
irrelevant it's useless
who gives a sh learn to code
and you'll be employed for the rest of
your life i lost a kid
24 year old kid to a big company in
cupertino
where he got paid 175 grand a year
and six hundred thousand dollars
guaranteed over four years in rsu's
and this he's not done anything ever
okay so all of you should teach your
kids how to code
all of you you should learn how to code
but my point is it's about skills now
and so that's another reallocation of
trillions of dollars
rule number eight don't fear mistakes
i'm not afraid to be wrong
like i just think being wrong is
overrated in the north american
philosophy we
we really look there are certain times
where you can't
be wrong if you're a pilot you can't be
wrong
right or a surgeon i get that or if
you're no it's not true actually
surgeons make mistakes all the time
they leave you know utensils or whatever
not utensils the
things inside the people's bodies i mean
you know um
but i i get how certain professions need
to value
the sort of like the binary distinction
of right and wrong
um but i think for most of us um it's
really sort of like you're either
learning or you're not learning
and i think we right now we create too
much of like a god complex around being
right
and we don't celebrate enough like the
fun process of iterating
you know and being able to like be in
the grind with people and
like like laugh when things don't work
that it's not like the end of the world
um
so i i think to me like that's probably
the single biggest thing that people
have to
uh get comfortable with which is like
just you're learning you're learning
and you either care about that or you
don't like if you're a good entrepreneur
like we were talking about this in the
green room nobody should grow up to be
an entrepreneur
i'm sorry that's i agree that's
ridiculous
you should grow up to be really angry
about something in your life
that you want to fix or change to make
better
do you know what i'm saying yes
um because then all of a sudden like
you're not going to give up when
something doesn't work
when something is wrong you're just
going to keep working at it because it's
learning but that mindset is only
possible in that context
so i i don't know i just think like
that's a that's a really important thing
to really internalize
rule number nine define your values i
think the most
important thing that you can do right
out of the box
is define your values
and i see so many people who when who
think it's like such a glib
thing when are asked to literally write
them down what you stand for
they stand for nothing and i think it's
very difficult
for you to be able to build something
when you don't know
your own true character because the way
that that
reflects itself unfortunately is you
make a bunch of mistakes in hiring
and those people may be good at
someplace else but if they're not good
for your company then what you have
are a bunch of disaffected people who
don't understand don't care the mission
and frankly will not go the extra mile
and it's
extremely corrosive and destructive and
so
i would say the single most important
thing is just to
literally write down what are your core
values
what do you believe unapologetically and
then don't
bend them and then when you're
evaluating someone
to work with you do they really express
those things and embody them and more
importantly
do you have a way of figuring out
whether they do or not
and asking the questions that allow you
to basically make those determinations
and when you get to an answer that
doesn't really reflect your values then
do you have the courage to say no
and it's hard in the early stage because
you're like man if this person says no i
have nobody else to work with what the
heck is going on
and i've just seen it now so many times
where we've kind of capitulated on that
and we've hired people into a bunch of
our companies and they've all failed
and when we look back systematically the
single biggest thing is they did not
embody the values that we had
that is the most important thing and
rule number ten the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is transfer knowledge you sometimes
like to take on a more hands-on role
with the companies that you work with or
is that normal of an investor or vc to
do i think it's probably atypical
i mean that's sort of why we've
constructed the space that we've
constructed
which is to have a lot of these really
interesting companies here very early on
and what it allows me to do is sort of
transfer knowledge i mean look
right now i've come out of sort of like
you know
12 years of operating some of the most
interesting consumer businesses that
have been built on the internet
and i've been a part of now three
massively seminal interesting products
winamp aim and icq facebook
and so there's a body of knowledge there
that's really relevant
but it's only relevant for a short
period of time four years from now i'll
be as dumb as any other vc
but in these next three or four years i
probably have some reasonable
knowledge to transfer and so the best
thing that i can do is make sure i'm in
a position to get that into
as many people as possible because then
at that point i'm what i'm hoping is
then i'll be able to learn from them
right because they'll really understand
the rules of how the next 10 years will
evolve
and then i'll be able to learn from them
and they'll feel
you know a sense of um not necessarily
obligation but like
you know that maybe hopefully a little
bit of you know gratitude of combined
with a little bit of
um um you know pity and then they'll
want to sort of you know
teach me now i've got a special bonus
clip that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action
but when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when
and how you're going to do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action
for the next week put it down in the
comments below so you can follow through
and i can celebrate you changing your
mind
is so powerful
i mean change your mind it it it makes
for
really really really bursty difficult
marriages at times
my wife will tell you but man is it
powerful in business
change your mind all the time
and it's amazing again where you'll find
like really good skilled leaders
want the right answer and they're fine
with capitulation they're fine with
change
they really are because they just want
the right answer and then you just get
so invested in an answer
and then you build up all of this
superficial logic to reinforce it
versus saying i don't know let me oh you
know what i changed my mind
wow another powerful thing i think i
cheat my mind all the time
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there